[Music]
thank you for joining us on a wolf and
sheep's clothing I'm blessings wi today
scientist Dr Eric Walsh returns to
reveal the media's hidden spiritual
agenda and its impact on social justice
and politics of the day welcome back Dr
Eric Walsh thanks for having me back we
want to jump right in what do you think
is causing witchcraft to rise in the US
so I think in our last session we talked
about the media's influence and how
children are being exposed to it I mean
simple television shows like door the
Explorer to um the famed Disney um
Fantasia where Mickey Mouse is a wizard
has introduced this and of course these
the massive uh popularity of books like
Harry Potter and the movies that spin
off of that and I can go on and on
obviously there are tons of different
ways that they're exposed to this but
what we find is as kids get older into
adolescence and we talked about this in
the last program the this loss of
purpose then they also have um be are
being almost trained to question almost
every form of establishment mhm so when
they when when there's a great article
why witchcraft Is On The Rise um and
what they talk about is that when kids
see
instability right when young people are
seeing instability one of the things
that happens is um and they don't trust
the establishment this is when they
actually turn to Witchcraft again we'll
go back to the Bible text Rebellion is
as the sin of Witchcraft there's some
connection there um and that's what I
think we're beginning to
see this is it's it's growing so fast
that it is in a sense in many ways
outpacing other religions like I think
we mentioned before the nuns the N
category so these people who used to be
in a franchised organized religion are
now calling themselves nuns or they're
being categorized that way because they
don't have a religion at all so it's
increasing also because they see it as a
weapon we mentioned that last time but
they see it as a a weapon almost a
revolutionary weapon against the
establishment so is there a lack of
control that they're sensing in their
lives that's causing them to look for
power in these forms of Witchcraft I
would say a lack of control a lack of
purpose um and then what the world says
is important is very selfish it's your
truth it's all about you um and so
witchcraft kind of begins to start to
answer that they get power from the
inside interestingly a lot of times it
overlays with Catholicism one of the
articles I read the woman got into
witchcraft but remained practicing cath
Catholicism so it's a the blend that we
talk we see in Revelation chapter 16 um
so all of these things are beginning to
happen um and they're frightening things
when you start to step back and look at
them frightening from the sense that
people are really asleep they don't know
what's going on and they believe they do
but there's another piece like I said
it's this social justice movement so one
of the other books is um revolutionary
witchcraft this book is a feminist guide
to using spells in incantations and so
forth to actually try and basically
overthrow kind of like the patriarchy
The Establishment whatever you want to
call it so you start pulling it all
together you create a world where the
new spiritual currency is social justice
it is um fighting against those who are
tyrannical old school
closed-minded here enters the
anti-religion to Christianity basically
witchcraft so we're going to back it up
just a little bit how media actually
helps infiltrate this because now it
makes me think back to I Love Lucy and
there you have a feminist agenda it
makes me think of uh Bewitched and I
love genie and how these women had to be
pretty much just uh deceitful women in
order to overcome the oppression of
their husbands absolutely you're saying
we're now we've been conditioned from
way back then and now this is actually
leading to overt witchcraft absolutely
and I've actually had patients who have
said to me that you know I wanted this
guy or whatever and you know so I went
and did some spell to get him and like a
love bind yeah love bind you know I'm
you know I'm like I feel sorry for the
guy I mean right know you're doing it
you're trying to do this you you might
have got him with just hello you know
exact you may not have even needed all
that conversation but you're right and
so what it is is it's it's a way again
what happens when you move God from the
center of a society and a
culture something is going to fill that
void and in some respects itself what
better than self than when you all the
things you're talking about on this
program everything from yoga to some of
the meditation stuff to mysticism to all
of it centers the media it all comes
back to me that's right ultim and here's
the key word it's Pride it's Pride if
you go to um Ezekiel 16:49 the Bible
says this was the sin of your sister
Sodom what was the number one sin pride
pride fullness of bread she was idle and
she did not uh take care of the poor and
needy the Bible says and then it says
and then she committed Abomination
Abomination came after what started was
Pride it was about self at the end of
the day spiritualism is an exercise in
self- worship so I actually don't see
much happening with the social justice
movement like when you talk about the
idleness you see a big you know uh
exhortation they're saying you know
shame on you blue lives you know what
you've done to us is is just ridiculous
what you've done is harmful but I don't
really see any legislation changing I
don't see a real uh impact when I think
of a movement in history that really
made an impact I think of people like
Martin Luther King and I don't see that
weighing out here so how how do you
explain that they get such media
attention but little comes of it well I
I would step back and say the Civil
Rights Movement was born out of the
church Christianity and the principles
of Christ right it was a nonviolent move
movement right
which was which basically was hung on
the principle of turn the other cheek I
mean you know you can go deeper but
fundamentally it was listen no matter
what they do to us we're going to stay
remain nonviolent and the world will see
wickedness for what it is and it will
change and that's exactly what happened
that did happen that's not the it's not
the Mantra now in fact I have slides in
some of my talks where they basically
say this is not your mother's civil
rights movement or your grandmother's
Civil Rights Movement they're going to
you know do what they have to do and so
you could be sitting in a restaurant
they come storming in in on people who
have nothing to do with anything
chanting and yelling and screaming and
disrupting uh the you know the person's
meal and that's not Godlike that's not
Christlike right there's no reason you
do that this is a new thing that's
happening so let me step back again what
we found though is when you start to do
the research and and we have an article
from the Los Angeles Times they can put
up black lives matter is a spiritual
movement and it talks about um how this
movement actually is born out of a lot
of the practices of West African to be
blunt West African Voodoo and the
founders themselves are feminist yes
very much feminist in fact on they took
the page down now off the BLM website
but I saw it with my own two eyes and
some others have said you know I'm not
wearing BLM stuff or doing it like some
of the athletes because they were like
this is this goes against my religious
beliefs but it was anti-nuclear family
as if a man wasn't didn't wasn't needed
to be in that family so it was a very we
see that repe repeated basically in epha
and these uh what you called obia oh
yeah types of worship where the man is
is denigrated and the woman is exalted
that can absolutely happen and in this
case that's exactly what they had on
that page and I'm sure you can find it
somewhere online but that's what they
were doing why is it relevant because I
was in you know I was in a meeting with
someone who was formerly a high ranking
US government official I'm trying to be
careful because I want to say the story
without saying who I'm talking about and
I'll never forget one of the people who
were activists for a certain Community I
remember them saying we have to destroy
the black church M they were saying this
loud I was I was at this next table we
were all in the same group where I was
on a committee and they were saying we
have to destroy the black church because
the black church is still preaching
things that should no longer be preached
they're not and Obama went into black
churches and actually said hey you guys
got to stop speaking against certain
things because so they literally
launched this attack you fast forward to
2020 and you have the Los Angeles that
article you have pastors pumping their
fists at a black black lives matter
meeting in
La as they call up the spirit of those
that have been killed by the police as
they pour out Libations as they call on
Nigerian goddesses and here are black
Pastors in fact some of our own
entangled in this necromancy and they
don't understand you you you can't you
know you can't you can't live in both
worlds no and if you really want the
World to Change that's that's it's okay
the church can do what it needs to do to
be involved in better policing in their
Community they can be involved I would
argue be involved in lowering crime in
your community as well as better
policing so that it it's easier on both
sides right but when this begins to
happen you can now inject into the
church directly spiritualism in the name
of social justice because the pillars of
your community are the ones introducing
it heralding it practicing it and
because it's all around you and what
what the viewers need to get is there is
an absolutely new way a new spiritual
economy is the way I'll say it and no
longer is it about being righteous like
Christ now it's being righteous in that
you fix this world right which God never
claimed was going to be eternity Jesus
says my kingdom is not of this world
right and this is one of the reasons he
was crucified so make it clear is God
asking us to be activists God is asking
us to be active but not necessarily
activists he the Bible calls us to go
out and to work on those issues in our
community that affect people especially
those that are disenfranchised and poor
but if it's only based on what we look
like we aren't really elevating right we
should be going out and looking for
anyone disenfranchised anywhere in the
world and doing a service for them
because when you isolate a group you
basically oppress the group that you're
not serving absolutely and here's where
it gets here's where it really gets kind
of
challenging if the church isn't careful
they can literally make the mistake the
children of Israel made at the time of
Christ are we speaking of barabus we're
speaking of barabus so let's so we if
you step back remember that after Jesus
fed the 5,000 they wanted to force him
to be king they were angry that he
wouldn't accept being King and that's
why Jesus sent them off in a boat by
themselves he retreated in the mountain
to pray for them and then the storm hit
them and he came walking to them on the
water so his inner circle had this
desire and so did the Jewish Nation at
large a lot of people when can you
imagine how effective Jesus would have
been as a revolutionary no the Roman
Empire let's just remember because
people don't get that Jesus actually
suffered more than we many of us have as
even as black Americans Jesus grew up in
a poor neighborhood Nazareth it was such
a questionable neighborhood that one of
his disciples said can anything good
come out of Nazareth so if you come from
a bad neighborhood he understands that
or a one of low reput reputation Jesus
said the foxes have of holes the birds
have Nest but the son of man has no
place to lay his head he understands
poverty Jesus understood oppression
because the Romans were and Daniel
chapter 7 Daniel chapter 2 when it
describes Rome it it's iron is the is
the metal used the legs in Daniel 2 it
was a crushing Force powerful muscles
teeth of iron crushing Force they were
under horrible oppression for decades
and they wanted to be free and they
wanted the The Throne of David to be
reestablished and they thought this guy
can do it can you imagine having a king
who could heal people if they got
stabbed in battle who could feed them if
they ran out of food by just breaking up
a little piece of bread this was the
King right he wouldn't take it you fast
forward all the way to where Palm Sunday
they're crying Hosanna Hosanna they're
ready okay here's our King we're we're
going to we're going to do this he's
going to do right by us he's going to do
right by us right the next week he's
standing next to Pilot with barabus
assumingly on the other side except now
Jesus has been beaten crown of thorn
been put on his head he looks emaciated
he looks weak but barabus is strong
barabus has committed murder for the
cause he has stolen for the cause he's
in started riots and they said listen we
want Barabas away with this man and give
us Barabas why even pilot said but this
I find no fault in this man it was
because they wanted their own Liberation
now I want to submit to you at any cost
necessary which is another political
movement that happened that didn't
really go anywhere and led to the death
of its absolutely who was raised
Adventist many people don't know
but this thing that happened with
barabus and Jesus when they were
standing there the people had to make a
decision do we want freedom and
Liberation now or do we want to wait for
this Kingdom to come that he's talking
about which is the whole point of being
selected and being called to be people
of God is you were supposed to be
studying prophecy and awaiting the
arrival and wait for him to point to the
New Direction and they weren't and I say
all of that to say this do not choose
barabus
today we have to be careful with with
the with feminist movements BLM and all
the other movements from all the
different communities you get caught up
in that and you want to fix it you want
righteous indignation that becomes your
new spiritual currency you miss true
spirituality you know what Jesus says
instead he says deny yourself take up
your cross right and follow me and that
is the movement for us today it is a
difficult movement because many people
think you're a good person when you
fight all of this oppression you you're
a good person when you stop the
patriarchy you're a good person when you
stop the heteronormative ways of society
I want to submit to you there's nothing
good in you no matter what you do and
one of the great um deceptions of the
occult is that somehow there is Divinity
inherently in you that goes all the way
back to the serpent in the garden with
Eve that ye shall be as gods that is
that is the the Crux of it and literally
that that has hit Black America Black
America got caught up in um the 5%
Nation of Islam the black man is God the
white man is the devil go back and look
at it that is the foundation of Hip Hop
everybody from Jay-Z to the wuang clan
the Big Daddy Kane all of these people
are 5centers this has been infused it is
a cult um a cult theology that has
become popularized to the point where
people don't even realize it and like
you said because it was in Hip Hop it
was disseminated amongst A specific
group and then it came to maturation and
here we are in the midst of it and it is
big now M it's big and it is pulling
young people out of church this the
Hebrew Israelites there's all these
movements pulling young black and Latino
especially young people out of the
church for the cause of the day so it's
causing destabilization and so there's
not going to be any progress because no
one can agree on the right action and
they're not looking up absolutely
they're looking within they're looking
inward which means they're really
looking down right so so you're right
but then again but there's power so if
you go back to Revelation you know if we
go back to I'm going to read uh
Revelation um 1613 just to read one of
the verses as to why this kind of a
thinking is so is so dangerous or I'll
read actually let me read Revelation 18
let's just the last part Revelation 18:
23 um it says for it says um for by thy
sorcery speaking of Babylon were all
nations deceived and in her was found
the blood of prophets and of saints and
of all that were slain upon the Earth
there will literally be an attack on the
people of God because of these movements
it is going to turn and come against us
and you have to get that now now when I
was when I was young um and I we moved
from Connecticut to
Miami and I went to a high school Miami
palmal senior high schools where I went
I actually gra graduated I'm in the same
yearbook with uh katangi Brown Jackson
and latest Supreme Court Justice we were
seniors together at Miami paleto High
School but that school was so racist MH
I mean they had these kids who wanted to
be Nazis I used to think they actually
were but now in hindsight I'm like
they're probably just kids thinking
confused just being bad they put SWAT
stickers all over stuff they would they
would I remember going into the bathroom
and used an racial exploitive go back to
Africa and it was horrible and I was
very hurt I came out of high school
angry and so I understand the spirit
behind a lot of what these people are
into you get hurt like that you want to
retaliate you want revenge you want all
of these different things even though
you grew up with a seven even though I
grew up in an Adventist home so did that
pull you out almost so luckily I was
rooted and grounded enough that I never
left but I studied with the Rastafarians
which is a form of spiritualism they now
worship a dead Haley salassi he's not
alive yet that's who they worship and
they had some theologies that kind of
were strange um including marijuana
smoking which will destroy your brain um
then I studied with the Nation of Islam
in fact at one time um I was so into the
Nation of Islam which is Lou faron's
organization that I'd get special
seating when he would come to town and
speak I grew up in Berkeley and he has a
famous bakery on the border of Berkeley
in Oakland so I I'm familiar with that
family Nation of Islam is big I studed
with a five% nation I used to go to all
look for all African people's
revolutionary party meetings so what I'm
hearing is that you were searching for
truth I even though you started with I
was searching for a way to dampen the
pain oh okay it wasn't truth because I
couldn't find it in any of them and I so
I'll jump to the end how I got out of it
was I actually went to go here at Louis
Faron on a Sabbath afternoon after
church
I was in medical school I went to the
Miami arena I was at the University of
Miami then and he said in one of his
messages the black man is the original
man and I said I've heard that before
but he said and I can prove it I said
okay I want to hear this he said 66
trillion years ago the black man blew
the moon off of the Earth with dynamite
I said what now I was sitting with these
two young ladies brilliant young ladies
a Haitian descent both in law school and
they and the other 8,000 people in the
Arena stood up and started Applause
plotting I said first of all 6 is it
because he showed documents I said first
of all how can you document 66 trillion
photographs crazy right there and then
and but then it was like said the
Chinese invented dynamite and that was
like 3,000 years ago how in the world
you know what I mean like doesn't
logically doesn't make sense then he
said I can prove it he said when the
astronauts went to the moon they could
still smell the
dynamite and I completely different
atmosphere the laws are different I
repented yeah fifth grade science tells
you the only thing you smelling on the
moon is what you brought with you from
Cape Canaveral or Houston that's right
right you you're not spelling on the
moon as you're dead 8,000 people appla
and I said in my I mean at sitting there
I i' gone to church that morning I
should have been at ay I said how close
am I dancing with the devil this is such
dangerous Doctrine and if race becomes
your
religion you're done true indeed because
you're not going to heaven to a
race-based heaven right regardless of
what side you're on doesn't matter and
and it's tough because the oppression is
real just like it was real for the the
Jews in fact in 8070 the Romans come in
and wipe them all out I mean it it
wasn't unreal who escaped the
destruction of the city of Jerusalem in
ad70 only the Christians why because
they listen to the prophecy of Luke CH
21 when Jesus said when you see the
abomination of desolation and the City
surrounded with armies leave right and
pray that your flight be not on the
Sabbath I mean Jesus laid it out and
those who understood prophecy lived to
actually build the next Kingdom they
heeded the word they heeded the word
instead of sticking to their own Laurels
absolutely and fashioning their own exit
plan right and if you're not careful and
let me let me you know I know we don't
have a lot of time so let me say this
piece of it we were talking on Backstage
and you can look this up online Snopes
actually verifi this as as mostly true
Hillary Clinton used to commune with um
um President Roosevelt's uh wife Elanor
Roosevelt you know as a spirit I guess
um Nancy Reagan when she was in the
White House had an
astrologer the Bible says that we
wrestle not against flesh and blood
white people are not your enemy and
white people black people aren't your
enemy no if you're a Christian you're
you understand from the scripture that
your enemy is Satan himself he's my
enemy right people aren't my enemy
people are victims of what sin has done
in this world and if I don't understand
that I will get I will get my into my
feelings but the Bible says it this way
uh we wrestle not against flesh and
blood but against spiritual wickedness
in high places yes if you looking at the
people around you and there your enemy
you you lost it already right you got to
remember that Lucifer the prince of the
air the one who thought he took this
planet as his own he is your enemy once
you understand that you'll want to be a
part of the Kingdom that opposes him and
then your Christianity will will begin
to fall into place your service in this
world will begin to fall in place
because you're not trying to serve to
fix this planet you're serving to build
the kingdom kingdom that's coming and
it's absolutely so what I'm hearing is
basically that we don't necessarily have
the correct answer in terms of social
justice to the oppression that's
happening what would you recommend
people start doing now to make a subtle
shift that could leave to a bigger shift
I think again I'll go back to what I
said on the previous episode God made
the human heart so big only he can fill
it and the world is in pain because as
we extract Christ from it it's funny as
bad as black people had it and we did
have it bad but during Jim Crow and
segregation the families were actually
more intact they were you know the the
the demand for Education was actually
higher right right so if we the truth of
the matter is what the world really does
Need Is Christ Jesus um and so our
churches in the inner city should have
tutoring programs for children that you
can that's social justice making sure
kids can read and and go on to school
and do well I remember when I was in in
La we Church aladen 7 Church our gym was
the only place the Bloods and Crips
would come and play together some of
those kids our youth pastor actually
took to Oakwood um to see Oakwood and to
expose them to that that's that's a good
form of social justice and it's low cost
low cost it requires very little
tutoring is low cost feeding programs
are LC us they're food banks feeding
people but you know one of a lot of our
churches feed people whatever they given
feed the best quality food ask I say
listen we want to feed them according to
the health message and here teach them
black people in America die from Health
disparities at a rate that is appalling
what if we were a place to create blue
zones in the neighborhood to transform
black lives we found that there are
things called black blue zones that
would be powerful social justice so some
of our viewers may not know what a blue
zone is blue zones are the part of five
areas in the world everywhere from iara
uh Greece to uh Italy to okanawa Japan
to a place in Costa Rica to lominda
California where where there are more
cenarius more people who live over the
age of a 100 and there are black blue
zones we found even our little church
the University of Connecticut approached
myself and one of the other black
doctors from one from our church that I
grew up at Faith SDA Church in Hartford
um and asked us how so many of the
people at that church in a neighborhood
where the average life expectancy is 65
how do so many of them live above 90 and
we were able to share with them the
health message that's social justice
right right and that is going to change
people's lives and actually add power to
their life strength to their life and
years to their life so we need programs
like that but let me say this do not be
afraid to preach the Everlasting gospel
the undiluted truth don't stand don't
don't think that if you because that's
ultimately what will liberate people
will take them out of their conditions
and Elevate them up if all you do is
preach to them where they are name it
claim it Prosperity Gospel you're not
really building people up no effect but
when you teach them that they must have
the character of Christ M yeah
everything around them then has to
change well this is so intense and I
know that our hours or a half hour is
winding down if there's a place that
they could go get a little bit more
information and hear one of your sermons
on this what would you say would be the
best place to go audioverse is a great
place to go if you go to audioverse.org
um there's a lot of sermons there I'm
doing a series right now on Last Day
Events um before that I did one on a new
start on the health message and and and
on on the sanctuary before that so there
plenty of materials there and our
churches The Three Angels Church in
Newton Connecticut the stuff on on there
but it's really not about me I mean the
more I I would like them to get a more
indepth understanding of what you're
talking about oh yeah and it's all there
true where you could cite you know
articles and show them just be able to
break it down more comfortable Pace you
know because this is just a half hour
segment no very true I'm I'm just saying
you know I don't no no but you are the
expert so that's why we we've called you
in but I what I really want to encourage
people of
all colors of all nationalities of all
languages is that there is a unity in
Christ so we're talking about social
justice social justice is fragmenting
society there's a good book I just read
how Civil Wars begin and that's
literally what they say has to happen
these are a liberal writer saying that
The Church Must Be The Place Jesus Says
by this will all men know that you are
my disciple disciples because you have
love one for another one of the proofs
of the remnant church is that we are a
diverse
ethnically diverse racially diverse
gender diverse like you know everybody
is here but we are unified in the Holy
Spirit unified under the blood of Christ
unified and caused to spread this gospel
finish this work so we can all go home
that is the antithesis to the social
justice occult movements of today
beautifully said closing thoughts Dr
Walsh my closing thoughts are that we
are watching the evisceration of society
of its Unity of how people come together
it's not an accident there's a whole ult
underswing pushing Us in this direction
but I want to encourage the viewers to
Turn Your Eyes Upon Jesus look full in
his wonderful face and the things of
Earth will grow strangely dim in the
light of his glory and grace that really
is the answer is that we must all turn
our eyes towards Christ and move in that
direction because this world's not going
to last very long and on that day when
when the when the Lord returns no why is
going to be able to sign up based on
race for what comes next it'll be
because we have the character of Jesus
Christ well said Dr Walsh thank you so
much for being
here the media has convinced people that
Christianity is oppressive and the cause
of our problems from the perspective of
God however all people regardless of
color have been oppressed by racism God
never intended the color of one's skin
to dilate Justice whether victims or
benefactors of the fruits of slavery we
all have been spiritually compromised
until next time time this has been a
wolf and sheep's
[Music]
[Applause]
clothing
[Music]